it's the coolest thing ever i get to do
something that brings me closer to
humanity kristen stewart is proud of her
role as princess diana and spencer i
think that that's also what diana
represented in a really like face and
simple way and the fact that this is
touching people and and so pervasively
is uh i think to her credit and i'm glad
to stand by and watch basically mommy
what's happened to make you so sad well
yeah
there is no future past and the present
to the same thing the 31 year old
actress is getting lots of award season
buzz for her performance in the biopic
including the spotlight award at the
palm springs international film festival
in january for her portrayal of the late
princess
can we go to the house where you used to
live it's brought it up
it's dangerous apparently
they said
it's dangerous you know
those voices like doors closing when e.t
caught up with kristen at the 2021
gotham awards she opened up about taking
on the big role it was kind of this like
amorphous pressure though because before
you do a movie you can't really picture
what it's going to be like and i just
knew that following pablo's vision and
sort of falling in the wake of his like
wild storm was going to be
weird and interesting and worth it as
for whether she got a review from the
palace well they're very discreet i
think quite typically even in response
because there's a lot of diana material
but royal material art multiplicity i
don't think that they really respond
often kristin has a lot to celebrate in
both her career and personal life the
twilight star got engaged to girlfriend
dylan meyer earlier this year and when
et asked her if she enjoys being a
fiance her answer was simple i mean yeah
that's why we did it